pour
[Musique]
je
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit de la vie des acteurs économiques
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines nous allons plonger dans le
secteur primaire de l'économie française
l'agriculture une activité présente à
saint quentin en yvelines avec 32
exploitation et 21 % de terres agricoles
des grandes cultures de l'élevage ou
encore du maraîchage et pour ce numéro
nous sommes à la ferme école graines
d'avenir elle ouvrira ses portes à
partir d'octobre 2021
c'est parti pour ce 22e numéro du sky
échos la start up les iroise banda qui
conçoit et fabrique un produit pour les
boxeurs un équipement pour remplacer les
bandages utilisé à l'entraînement la
ferme-école graines d'avenir lance sa
première formation à manille les
errements en octobre prochain
des enseignements pour devenir
maraîchers primeurs qui drive ou une
application développée par karine sebaâ
magny les hameaux
une solution pour permettre aux parents
de mutualiser les trajets pour emmener
leurs enfants sur les activités
extrascolaires découverte d'un
entrepreneur engagé dans le monde du
sport et plus particulièrement dans la
boxe franck romeo a créé la start-up
bande axe basée à plaisir il fabrique un
produit qui remplace les bandages de
protection des mains des boxeurs pour
leurs entraînements
il fournit notamment plusieurs champions
qui vont participer aux jo c'est la
séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur avec
franck romeo
le dirigeant de bandes axe
[Musique]
je m'appelle franck romero je suis le
fondateur et le signe aux deux bandes
axe c'est une marque qui fabrique des
bandages pour la protection des mains
des combattants multidisciplines nous
vous sommes basés sur plaisir dans les
yvelines depuis 2017
[Musique]
macrez justement un produit pour
protéger les mains des boxeurs s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait un problème à
ce niveau-là notamment à l'entraînement
on a à coeur de toujours protéger les
boxeurs du mieux possible pour qu'ils
puissent performer être au top de leur
forme
[Musique]
j'ai commencé avec trois rouleaux de
bande et 600 euros en poche je
travaillais à côté donc j'étais je
travaillais la journée le soir j'allais
à la salle m'entraîner entraîné les
petits aussi plus qu'à l'époque je
passais mon diplôme de coach et le soir
je fabriquais les pères pour pour les
clients tout s'est fait sur fonds
propres en fait gérés injecter chaque
vente m'a permis de faire améliorer le
produit
on a eu à coeur de créer et de
développer un concept est un produit
unique au monde qui permettait d'avoir
un bandage professionnels mais surtout
réutilisables dans le temps
[Musique]
le chiffre d'affaires a doublé ces
dernières années donc on est très
contents actuellement on est consulté
pour plusieurs milliers de paires nous
avons exporté des bandages dans 35 pays
sur les 5 continents notamment dans des
pays comme les etats-unis la chine la
russie le japon le brésil c'est aussi ça
le rôle d'une start-up ces deux aussi
pouvoir être évolutif et de pas être
figé aujourd'hui si on doit investir
dans une machine trouver une nouvelle un
nouveau composant une nouvelle méthode
on va forcément la mettre en place pour
proposer le meilleur aux boxeurs et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est de
toujours pouvoir proposer le meilleur
[Musique]
elle date du 15ème siècle la ferme de
bus loyer à magny les hameaux va
accueillir en octobre prochain la
ferme-école graines d'avenir une école
de production qui va former au métier de
maraîcher et primeurs pour en parler
nous sommes avec bruno et marc le co
fondateur de cette école bonjour bonjour
nicolas
alors en quoi consistent les formations
vous allez proposer à partir du mois
d'octobre alors nous assurons nous
allons associer agro écologie et
enseignement innovants pour former des
jeunes aux métiers maraîchers primeur
donc à la production la transformation
et la vente de fruits et légumes frais
des formations destinées à quel type de
profil alors on s'adresse à des jeunes
dès 15 ans qui voudrait trouver une voie
complémentaire entre le lycée
professionnel ou parfois ils trouvent
que c'est trop d'écoles pas assez de
vécu du métier et le cfa où ils n'ont
parfois pas la maturité pour se
retrouver seul dans un monde d'adultes
c'est une formation qui donne accès à
quel diplôme du coup à la fin alors à
deux diplômes professionnels d'état sur
trois ans on va les former au cercle et
primeurs qui est un diplôme qui existe
depuis 2018 qui reconnaît le savoir
faire spécifique de la vente de fruits
et légumes frais derrière vos rayons et
au titre professionnel d'ouvriers de
production horticole de la graine
jusqu'à la plante et sa
commercialisation
pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans cette
aventure
pourquoi on s'est lancé dans cette
aventure la volonté de
d'avoir un impact sur les enjeux
alimentaires de notre territoire que ce
soit agriculture locale les circuits
courts mais aussi la volonté de
travailler sur l'insertion des jeunes la
lutte contre le décrochage de scolaires
et la lutte contre le chômage des jeunes
je disais au début de cette émission
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses 21 % de
terres agricoles c'est 32 exploitation
installés sur le territoire c'est aussi
rendre attractif ces métiers peut-être
que s'il ya des besoins aussi par
rapport à ces acteurs de l'agriculture
locale alors une école de production
c'est un écosystème entre les
territoires les jeunes et les
entreprises les territoires je voulais
dit lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
lutte contre le chômage des jeunes les
jeunes leur proposer une troisième voie
et les entreprises c'est mettre sur le
marché des jeunes rapidement
opérationnel et former au métier
d'ailleurs nous allons commercialiser
aussi nos produits c'est à dire que les
jeunes vont pratiquer le métier ils vont
répondre à des vraies commandes vrais
clients aux conditions du marché et donc
lorsqu'ils vont intégrer une entreprise
ils auront déjà sept cette pratique
merci bruno ai marre je rappelle que
vous êtes le co fondateur de la ferme
école graines d'avenir
et puis maintenant on va aller découvrir
justement le contenu des formations
c'est ça oui tout à fait on va les
rejoindre donatien qui est notre maître
professionnels
maraîcher et qui aujourd'hui travaillent
à mettre en exploitation la ferme pour
accueillir nos élèves en octobre il est
d'ailleurs en train de planter des choux
c'est parti allons-y
[Musique]
alors du coup ça ce sont des choux c'est
ça oui ce sont des choux et cette fois
ce sont des choux 2001 des choux frisés
d'accord alors le principe là ça va être
nous ce qu'on a on a préparé ce qu'on
appelle un match c'est à dire une
protection végétale au dessus du sol
pour protéger le sol et retenir
l'humidité les rayons du soleil tape
moins le sol et l'humilité rap bien
reste bien le soleil en plus c'est de la
matière organique ou ça va nourrir le
sol et le principe ça va être de
traverser ce match
comme quoi on traverse la paille et le
broyat on va chercher la terre le broyat
c'est la terre noire c'est ça exactement
on est parti la chercher c'est tout ce
que les gens jettent en déchetterie
d'accord voilà on cherche bien ces deux
là et ensuite on va enfoncer le plan à
l'intérieur voilà et on referme la terre
et en termes bien le must pour cueillir
uniquement le chou qui sortent de notre
couvert d'accords voilà et on avance
comme ça petit à petit toujours en
quinconce donc comme le disait bruno et
marin l'idée c'est aussi de pratiquer sa
voix la c1 ce qui est important avec les
écoles de production c'est le faire pour
apprendre c'est à dire au lieu de leur
dire on fait comme si on fait comme ça
on va directement sur le terrain est
alors monde comment ça se passe
directement la production
ben justement on va se retrouver tout à
l'heure devant le plan de chou et puis
pour nous expliquer le contenu de ces
formations et qui en attendant on va
continuer à planter les choux
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
finalement là vous êtes en train de
préparer les parcelles pour la formation
au mois d'octobre
c'est ça alors on est actuellement en
train de préparer des parcelles qui vont
servir à récolter et à récolter des
choux pour l'hiver parce que les élèves
ont mis un soin à partir d'octobre
on a planté tous les légumes de
conservation qui vont pouvoir durer tout
l'automne et tout l'hiver pour que les
élèves puissent récolter des choux
pendant la formation
alors concrètement qu'est ce que vous
aller enseigner à ses élèves
on va enseigner toutes les tâches
pratiques qui va y avoir en maraîchage
c'est-à-dire semer la graine
l'entretenir s'occuper de l'arrosage la
plantation savoir connaître une mauvaise
herbe savoir reconnaître une lap la
plante savoir reconnaître les maladies
pouvoir utiliser les produits qui vont
avec où les traitements qu'on utilise en
agriculture biologique et après récoltés
et mettre en forme les légumes pour
ensuite les vendre à savez de quoi une
semaine type aa la ferme école de
graines d'avenir amman il aime la
semaine type ça va être le lundi matin
un petit peu d'exercice en ce moment
chaud après le week-end un peu difficile
on regarde un peu l'état des parcelles
ont fait le point ensemble de tout ce
qui va se passer pendant la semaine on
regarde les gros chantiers des petits
chantiers ont réparti les tâches sur
fonction des différents ateliers ceux
qui vont gérer l'arrosage ceux qui vont
gérer la plantation ceux qui vont gérer
la survie des cultures les récoltes etc
et ensuite on va directement sur le
terrain planter récolter désherber faire
tout l'ensemble des tâches comme
maraîcher fait habituellement c'est
combien d'heures par semaine de
formation normand de ses 35 heures sur
les écoles de production il faut savoir
les écoles de production ses 35 heures
avec deux tiers de thé de pratiques
pardon et un tiers de théorique c'est à
dire qu'ils vont passer deux tiers du
temps vraiment sur le terrain soit
culture et les légumes soient les vendre
et ensuite un tir de théorique où on va
leur apprendre les matières générales
mathématiques français anglais et c'est
toujours lié avec le maraîchage par
exemple on va d'abord planter des choux
là on regarde le nombre de densité il
s'est ensuite le professeur de
mathématiques qui va venir voir keaven
aux élèves comment ça se fait que vous
avez réussi à planter les choux
quelle densité vous avez utilisé ils du
coup la plantation de choux va servir un
support pour pouvoir faire de
l'enseignement théorique
combien d'élèves vont être accueillis à
partir de ne pas partir d'octobre ce
serait une promo de 12 élèves qui va y
avoir
vous les avez déjà on en a eu une bonne
partie mais on va se réserver un petit
peu pour la fin de l'été étant donné
qu'il ya une grosse partie de
recrutement qui suit en septembre on
laisse encore des places libres
donc on peut toujours s'inscrire alors
sur le site internet de la ferme-école
exactement vous nous contactez on vous
en voir
nous rencontrons vous envoie ensuite un
formulaire d'inscription est on avec le
plaisir vous accueille en octobre et
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas d'écran merci et donatien merci à
vous de venir rappelle que vous êtes
remettre professionnels le maraîcher
voilà merci à vous bonne journée quand
le digital vient faciliter la vie
quotidienne des familles c'est la
solution proposée par la start up qui
drive vous installer à magny les hameaux
karine sebha vient de développer une
plateforme sur internet pour permettre
aux familles de s'entraider pour le
trajet de leurs enfants jusqu'aux
activités extrascolaires les détails
dans cet instant ico
[Musique]
ans
en
c'est une plateforme de mise en relation
entre parents qui sert à covoiturer ou
accompagner les enfants aux trajets
d'activités extrascolaires uniquement
entre parents souvent les parents n'ont
pas forcément la disponibilité en terme
d'agenda à mardi à 17 heures 1 mercredi
matin à 10 heures alors que d'autres
parents sont disponibles pour faire ce
trajet
[Musique]
on s'inscrit simplement sur le site qui
drive ou points comme on renseigne ses
trajets d'activité que ce soit un trajet
pour une mise en relation avec une
personne trois trajets cinq trajets égal
à cinq mises en relation avec ce qu'on
appelle les qui driver les parents
accompagnateurs
on prend le forfait qui est adapté à son
nombre de mises en relation et on n'a
plus qu'à définir toutes ces activités
il ya deux modèles en fait quand on
s'inscrit et qu'on cherche un trajet on
peut aussi sans obligation mais on peut
devenir un qui drivers pour accompagner
aussi les enfants des autres et faire un
réseau de parents de confiance on peut
aussi être un qui driver bénévoles
évidemment il ya toute une sécurité qui
est mise en place pour l'accompagnement
des enfants
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi je remercie tous les
journalistes qui m'ont accompagné dans
les entreprises du territoire est aussi
un coup de chapeau aux équipes
techniques pour le montage des émissions
on se retrouve à la rentrée pour de
nouvelles aventures entrepreneuriales et
d histoire économique à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]